Speaker 1: If you thought that the idle chatter
about a coup like in Myanmar and Trump posting
to his blog about audits were happening in
a vacuum, you were very much wrong.
The New York Times Maggie Haberman is now
reporting that Donald Trump is telling people
privately he will be reinstated as president
of the United States by August of this year.
This is actually something that more and more
kuhnen people are attaching to now.
Now, the context here is that on Sunday night,
Trump's former national security adviser,
Michael Flynn, remember the guy who was indicted
and convicted and then pardoned by Trump?
He said to an audience that there should be
a coup here like the one that took place in
Myanmar.
That's outrageous enough.
But this appears to be part of I hesitate
to call it a political movement, but it's
part of something that Trump is again ginning
up, which again might lead to real violence.
So here is the latest from The New York Times
Maggie Haberman, who tweeted yesterday that,
quote, Trump has been telling a number of
people he's in contact with, that he expects
he will get reinstated by August.
No, that isn't how it works, but simply sharing
the information.
Now, the concept of reinstated is hilarious
when, you know, the process of four presidents
becoming president is being elected.
Reinstated is not a term that applies to the
presidency.
It's you, your elected and then you're inaugurated
and then you serve.
Who would reinstate him is the idea of the
Supreme Court.
How would that work?
It doesn't make any sense.
Maggie Haberman goes on to say, quote, It
isn't happening in a vacuum.
It is happening as he faced the possibility
of an indictment from the Manhattan district
attorney.
And then lastly, adding that, quote, He is
not putting out statements about the audits
and states just for the sake of it.
He's been laser focused on them, according
to several people who've spoken with them,
as well as Washington Post reporting a few
weeks ago.
Now, whether Donald Trump thinks he'll be
back by CU or by some other means isn't clear.
But the entire Myanmar style coup thing to
take Joe Biden out of the White House has
been floating around Kuhnen circles for months.
And here's an interview done by CNN with such
people, I guess we would call them, who have
the same idea.
Speaker 2: Biden is just he's like a puppet
president.
The military is in charge.
It's going to be like Myanma.
What's happening in Myanma?
The military is doing their own investigation.
And at the right time, they're going to be
restoring the republic with Trump as president
and different country.
Speaker 3: Now, government been over and they're
redoing the election can't possibly happen
here, possibly.
Would you like to see it?
Perhaps.
Really like to see.
Yes.
You know why?
Because the election was stolen from us.
Speaker 1: I would take any bet that this
is the first time most of these people have
even heard of Myanmar.
I mean, seriously, and certainly the first
time they've ever pretended to care about
it.
So, of course, none of it will happen.
But in the process of not happening, if it
just gets enough oxygen, it might inspire
more violence.
It's easy to laugh and to say ignore this
crap, forget it or whatever.
But these are dangerous delusions.
They are delusions.
But after the January six Trump riots, we
can't say they are merely delusions.
They are dangerously deluded.
Now, some are already saying put two and two
together.
David Michael Flynn says there should be a
coup.
Trump is thinking about August.
Trump is planning a violent coup.
We can't say that yet.
I wouldn't put it past Trump to try it and
it wouldn't work.
But we really shouldn't say that he is planning
a violent coup because we don't know that.
And that would be irresponsible.
Would he be morally opposed to it?
No, probably not.
Are we to expect new arbitrary announcements
about August, September?
What up for the next few years?
Probably this helps with fundraising.
I'm sure many of them probably don't realize
it's never going to happen.
And once August comes and goes, it'll be January
and then it'll be listen, the way to take
this back is actually to vote Republicans
in in November of twenty twenty two so that
they take control back of Congress.
Then we can impeach Biden and replace him
with Donald Trump.
It'll just.
Keep going and going and going, it's the never
ending grift, but this is my last thought
and this is important.
If this is true that Donald Trump is seriously
telling people I'll be reinstated as president
by August, it's a grift, but it's not just
a grift.
It's working to grift money from people.
But if Trump really believes it himself, that's
scarier than Trump merely being a con man.
He is a con man.
But then he also seems as deluded himself
as are many of his followers.
And to me, that's even scarier.
Let me know what you think.
Let me know what percentage of Trump's followers
really believe Trump could be reinstated by
August and how many understand that that's
just never, ever, ever going to happen.
We'll take a quick break and be right back
after this.